[Music]
I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
talking about high fall so last video we
talked about you know why - so there's a
lot of mysticism and myth in the high
fallin and we kind of need to let that
go through go let that go in order to
progress through with Aikido but at the
same time there are functions to tighten
and we do need to know how to do it for
you to practice so today we're gonna
talk about how to actually start doing
your first high fall so how do you make
your first high fall happen and it can
be a daunting process so I'm gonna give
you my beginner high fall practice which
if you can do is simple kite in a
regular four role you should be able to
do this high fall with no problem at all
so I'm gonna get Josh out here and we're
gonna go to work for you guys Josh okay
so how do you build up the height balls
the first thing you have to be able to
do is do a successful forward roll wall
close to somebody so there's the first
step you have to have and then you need
to be able to do a forward roll while
someone's in contact with you and that
might sound easy but until you've done
it there's a lot of obstacles you can
hit with that so I have a rolling
progression that I use but just real
quick give you the rough idea of it is
so if Josh and I were like this here
we're really close to proximity I touch
Josh so that way I'm in contact with it
and then Josh does a nice board roll
okay so if once he can do that then you
can start to work up the high falls
really easy okay it's important to
understand that high Falls are called
booty chiton who communes to float
cotton means to roll so that's literally
what it is it's just a forward roll it's
really not much different than simple
chi 10 except you turn all the way over
when you do it before touching the
ground so you don't touch the ground you
float past the ground and flip over the
way over to all the way over to the
other side so here's a nice progression
for that so if Josh and I were to stand
chest to chest like this so this is the
same as we were second go and we know
Josh can do a forward roll with that
okay I'm gonna turn this way and I'm
ready get Josh's forward hand like this
and all I'm gonna do is touch it then
Josh is gonna line up
to enroll that direction and then he's
gonna do the role and I'm just touching
his hand here just like as if I was
holding it
the next thing Josh gonna do is I'm
gonna grab his wrist and hold it josh is
gonna reach over the top of my arm like
this put his hand here on my knee
now all Josh is gonna do is a forward
roll and I'm gonna provide the butt base
so when he rolls
he doesn't smash down right so all I'm
doing is holding him so he's doing the
forward roll if he has a hard time doing
this and say we got someone who starts
trying to pay allowing can you do a
bailout anymore yeah there we go good
okay so that's like a bad bailout right
and that's because josh is scared so if
I get someone who's doing that I'm gonna
go back to this and I'm gonna tell him
hey I'm not gonna hold you just go ahead
and do it for roll and make sure that
they can do that action again right
because they'll see immediately if they
can do it for a roll and they try and
bail out of the roll they'll see that
that's an awkward action right so we get
here like this and then once you can do
that again I'm gonna hold him and say go
ahead and try that full roll again
and there's this high pole so the high
balls really no difference in simple
kite em except there's a floating moment
there that that happens and I think this
practice is really good to get you
started with it prax is really simple
you line up face to face like this you
grab it Yakub so I'm just grabbing right
across josh reaches over my arm like
this I give him a little base so I put
my leg down here so you can grab it I
hold it real strong now it's important
that I'm able to hold this guy right so
you would like to have a bigger guy in
this role and not a bigger guy in this
role if you can especially when they're
not sure about it yet so I'm gonna hold
him real strong he's going to do that
for roll comes over perfect tight ball
okay in the next video we're gonna talk
about how to refine those and some tips
for high balls or how to make your high
Falls a little bit better I'm
Christopher Heim thanks for watching
[Music]